>>> TODAY IS PRIMARY DAY, AND
U SEE THE FIVE STES VOTING
TODAY, ARIZONA, KANSAS,
MICHIGAN, MISSOURI AND
WASHINGTON.
IN KANSAS, THE FIRST STATE-WIDE
VOTE ON ABORTION RIGHTS.
SOME OTHER KEY DYNAMICS AS WE
WATCH TONIGHT, REMEMBER THE TEN
HOUSE REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP.
FIVE OF THEM ARE ALREADY OUT OF
PLAY, IF YOU WILL, IN THE SENSE
THAT THEY EITHER DECIDED NOT TO
RUN OR LOST THEIR PRIMARIES.
THREE, THREE OF THE TEN HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP FACE PRIMARIES
TODAY AND FACE CANDIDATES
ENDORSED BY DONALD TRUMP.
TWO OUT OF WASHINGTON STATE, ONE
IN MICHIGAN.
SO WE'LL KNOW A MUCH BETTER
TALLY BY THE END OF THE TONIGHT.
ALSO SOME OTHER FASCINATING
RACES, I MENTIONED THAT KANSAS
VOTE.
EVERYBODY IS WATCHING THAT FOR
VOTER INTENSITY.
YOU'VE GOT SOME KEY GOVERNORS
PRIMARIES AND SENATE PRIMARIES.
OUT OF THE STATE OF ARIZONA, IT
IS POSSIBLE FOR A GOVERNOR, FOR
UNITED STATES SENATE.
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES IN
ARIZONA, ONE OF THE TROUBLING
THEMES IN THIS ELECTION YEAR,
ELECTION DENIERS.
>> THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN WIN IS
IF THEY LOAD UP THE VOTER ROLES
WITH DEAD PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO
HAVE MOVED, AND IMAGINARY
FRIENDS.
>> SOMEONE WHO IS NOT AFRAID TO
TAKE ON THE CROWD AND TELL THEM,
YOU NEED TO MOVE ON.
NOTHING HAPPENED.
IT'S OKAY.
DONALD TRUMP LOST.
CHEATING IS NOT WINNING.
>> WHAT THE RADICAL LEFT HAS
DONE BY HIJACKING OUR ELECTIONS
IS WRONG.
>> WITH ME TO SHARE THEIR
REPORTING AND INSIGHTS,
MARGARET, BLOOMBERG'S MARY OWE
PARKER.
TOO MUCH TO TALK ABOUT.
LET'S START THERE.
I CALL IT TROUBLING.
YOU STILL HAVE T, EVEN AFTER THE
BIG LIE, YOU STILL HAVE SOME
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES WHO FLAT
OUT REPEAT THE 2020 LIE, OR EVEN
MORE TROUBLING, YOU HEARD THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE, IF I LOSE,
THERE'S CHEATING.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS A PRETTY COMMON THEME IN
THE REPUBLICAN RACES THIS YEAR.
LIKE YOU SAID, IT'S VERY
TROUBLING GIVING EVERYTHING WE
HAVE SEEN AT THE JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS.
I THINK MORE TROUBLING IS THE
IMPLICATIONS HEADING INTO 2024
IF THESE GOVERNORS, SECRETARY OF
STATES, ATTORNEY GENERALS ARE
ELECTED BECAUSE THEY WILL BE THE
ONES OVERSEEING THESE ELECTIONS
AND THE COUNTING OF THE BALLOTS.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE THREE
CANDIDATES TODAY, THREE OF THE
TEN VOTED TO IMPEACH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SO WE GET A SENSE EARLIER, FIRST
YOU GET THE MICHIGAN RACE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO WATCH, NUMBER
ONE, DOES TRUMP GET HIS
VENGEANCE AGAINST THESE THREE,
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE PUT MONEY
INTO THE MICHIGAN RACE TRYING TO
HELP MYER'S OPPONENT.
TO WHICH PETER MYER RUNS THIS
OUT ON THE RIDE OWE.
>> NANCY PELOSI IS BUMPING HALF
A MILLION DOLLARS TO TRY TO BUY
THIS ELECTION AND RYE TO FOOL
CONSERVATIVES INTO VOTING FOR
JOHN GIBBS.
>> THIS IS NOT THE ONLY RACE
WHERE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
PUT THEIR THUMB ON THE SCALE BY
HELPING A REPUBLICAN -- THE HOPE
IS THE REPUBLICAN WINS A PRIMARY
WHO CANNOT WIN IN NOVEMBER.
>> WE SAW CONGRESSMAN RICHEY
TORREZ SAYING OVER THE WEEKEND
HE WAS DISPLEASED WITH SOME OF
THESE MANEUVERS.
IT SEEDS THE MORAL HIGH GROUND
FOR DEMOCRATS.
IT'S A RISKY STRATEGY.
IT'S A TWO-PRONGED STRATEGY.
RIGHT NOW, THAT'S AN IFFY
SITUATION.
>> THAT'S THE POLITE WAY TO PUT
IT.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ARIZONA
GOVERNORS RACE WHERE YOU HAVE
THE BROADCASTER SAYING SHE'S
CHANNELING TRUMP.
IF I LOSING WITH SOMEONE'S
CHEATING.
AND THEN YOU HAVE KAREN ROBSON.
WHERE ARE WE AS WE GET DEEPER
INVENTORY PRIMARY SEASON?
WHO'S WINNING?
>> SO FAR, TRUMP'S WINNING, AND
ARIZONA WILL BE A BIG TEST TO
THAT.
I THINK LIZ CHENEY IS GOING TO
BE AN EVEN BIGGER TEST.
NOBODY IS HIDING HOW MANY
DIFFERENT MONEY STREAMS THERE
ARE AFTER REPUBLICANS AS WELL AS
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO LEFT HER UP.
I THINK WHEN YOU REALLY ZOOM
OUT, DEMOCRACY IS HUGELY ON THE
BALLOT TODAY.
I JUST CAN'T MISS THE POSITION
OF NANCY PELOSI LANDING AND
SAYING IN HER PUBLIC COMMENTS
AND WRITINGS, THIS IS ABOUT
ELEVATING A DEMOCRACY, THIS
CRUCIAL DEMOCRACY, AND LOOK AT
THE TESTS AT HOME ON THE BALLOT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT P
BIPARTISANSHIP.
>> AND I MENTIONED IT'S JUST
ABOUT -- IT'S A POSSIBILITY THAT
REPUBLICANS IN ARIZONA WILL HAVE
A STATE-WIDE SLATE OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE ELECTION DENIERS.
>> I DO THINK THAT CAN HURT THE
REPUBLICANS CHANCES ON THE
PIVOTAL.
IT COULD ALL COME DOWN TO WHO
CONTROLS THE SENATE.
THAT RACE WILL BE SO PIVOTAL,
AND IF ARIZONA GETS A SLATE OF
CANDIDATES WHO COULD HELP MARK
KELLY'S CHANCES OF HOLDING ON TO
THAT SEAT.
>> ARIZONA WILL BE CRUCIAL THIS
YEAR AND IN 2024.
TRUMP VERY BELATEDLY ENDORSED
THE CANDIDATE ON THE LEFT.
YOU HAVE RYAN KELLY THERE AS
WELL IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
YOU HAVE IN A MAJOR STATE IN THE
MIDDLE OF AMERICA, CRITICAL THIS
YEAR, CRITICAL AGAIN IN 2024.
ELECTION LIES ARE STILL A
DOMINANT THEME.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS RACE IS REALLY INTERESTING.
I THINK THIS RACE IS PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT FOR TRUMP AND
IN A LOT OF WAYS, DEMOCRATS
TODAY BECAUSE MICHIGAN IS MUCH A
PIVOTAL STATE IN 2024, YOU NEED
IT TO WIN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT WE SAW HERE WAS TRUMP AND
THE DEVOS FAMILY HAVE BEEN AT
WAR WITH EACH OTHER AND SO MANY
OTHER RACES DOWN IN THE BALLOT,
AND SHE WROTE HIM THIS LETTER
THAT MADE NO MENTION OF JANUARY
6th AND SAID, YOU SHOULD ENDORSE
THIS CANDIDATE, AND THEY CAME
TOGETHER ON THIS RACE.
SO IT'S SUCH AN INTERESTING
DYNAMIC IN THAT STATE.
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, IF THEY
CANNOT WIN THE GOVERNORSHIP,
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT THEIR
CHANCES IN 2024?
>> AND IF WE CAN PUT ON THE
SCREEN AGAIN, YOU SEE FIVE OR
WHO DECIDED NOT TO RUN FOR
ELECTION OR NOT TO RUN IN THEIR
PRIMARY.
THE CHIENY PRIMARY THIS MONTH,
THREE TODAY.
DO WE SEE ANY EVIDENCE THAT THE
JANUARY 6th HEARINGS AND TRUMP'S
REEMERGENCE HAVE CHANGED?
CAN CHENEY SURVIVE?
ARE REPUBLICANS HAVING SECOND
THOUGHTS ABOUT ONE OF THIS IS
THE QUESTION?
>> THAT'S THE THING.
WE HAVE ALL BEEN WRITING ABOUT
TRUMP'S GRIP ON THE PARTY WITH
THIS PRIMARY.
SO NOW IS WHERE THE RUBBER HITS
THE ROAD NOW THAT WE'VE HAD THE
PUBLIC JANUARY 6th HEARINGS.
WE SAW SOME DAMAGE TO TRUMP'S
REPUTATION AND BRAND WITH SOME
OF THOSE DAMNING HEAVY LAGSS
THAT CAME OUT.
WE'LL SEE WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
A FUTURE.
>> CANDIDATES IN WASHINGTON
STATE MAY BE VERY POISED.
>> THAT'S A TOUGH DISTRICT.
IT'S A CONSERVATIVE DISTRICT.
IT'S NOT BEEN GOOD FOR LIZ
CHENEY SO FAR.